we are going to take a look at a
political apprenticeship we all sit at
the knee of bill clinton when it comes
to figuring out how to get people to
vote for you here we have bruce braley
whose name uh the obamas mispronounced
when they were out there that's good
yeah right exactly but bill clinton
knows how it's done there this this is a
uh a an outfit for the clinton's
granddaughter charlotte
and look how thrilled he is look he's
just thrilled to be alive he's thrilled
to be bill clinton look at that smile
this ticker's running everything's good
this isn't good
ugly for mr braley this weekend i will
tell you all you need to know about this
election this event is barbecue being
held in waterloo iowa okay
that is what it's looking like for the
dems number two first
this is nick wallenda a daredevil oh
that's actually
bruce braley who's about to lose but
okay nick wallenda uh daredevil walking
a tightrope from marina city's west
tower in downtown chicago to the top of
the 670 foot 71 foot tall leo burnett
building he broke two records one for
the steepest tightrope walk 19 degrees
this is in chicago
i thought this is the only keynesian at
the university of chicago
the highest blindfolded walk
700 feet above
the street level you know there's no
tight there's no uh safety in that there
i'm just counting down between when tom
says keynesian and blindfolded five four
three two
peter coy joke
the cover of bloomberg this week uh our
last
item no wait wait we're still we're
still in chicago here come on we're
looking okay we're looking at chicago
but here's are you kidding he's got a
gopro on his head
i mean if you were that guy wouldn't you
want to capture it he's blindfolded how
else is he going to know what it looked
like how does he do that by the way the
winds were blowing at 25 miles per hour
when this happened
i want to know why they didn't put the
little blinky kid sneakers on him oh so
you could see this idea
are you kidding me
his father his father died actually
attempting the same feat
so there's a little family history if he
does this does he become the manager of
the chicago cubs
i i want you all to know something
what you missed in this morning's story
meeting at 5 00 a.m was the sight of tom
keane eating donuts he's the he is the
nick he's the nick willenda of donut
consumption
our photo of the day is sitting here on
the desk uh this is not a cronut it is a
croissant
doughnut that's because krona is
trademarked because cronut is
trademarked but dunkin donuts has
finally started
really a leftover cronut when we have
another 11 here on the street
gentlemen would
gentlemen would you like one of the
cronuts that tom keane has not taken a
bite i'm on a low carb diet thank you
but i'll pass them
what we're hearing from the control room
is that we need to uh hold on to some of
them for the producers they're for
radios is this what you want is this
what you want right here
um right here no these are different i
got your products right here control
room they've got them right here
well yeah they're different from the
creditors how much are these possible
like we were able to get a dozen
i never had a chronic because i never
had two hours to wait in the line
this was 350 a piece of paper 350 a
piece the actual chronet is
inflation so how do you figure that into
the cpi because they didn't exist what a
week ago
you know how does that work into the cpi
tom by himself is moving
who says there's no innovation